the livelihood of millions of people in
Lahore depends on these buffaloes
Muhammad Akbar has tended his Herd on
the banks of the Ravi River for years
now he is among the farmers threatened
with eviction to make way for the
world's largest Riverfront City
I have five acres of land for
Generations but the government Authority
has taken it without my consent on a
very low price now want me evicted or
should I take both my family and
livestock
Human Rights Watch says since 2020 more
than 100 Farmers have been charged for
resisting or refusing to hand over land
it's urged the government to stop
intimidation harassment and use of force
the Ravi Riverfront Urban Development
Authority or Ruda denies the accusations
it says the problem is that people have
occupied the land for years but don't
legally own it we're not disturbing any
settlements unless they are coming in
the riverbed
so there will be relocation of people
who are in the riverbed because that's
the path of river
Pakistan sailing economy is struggling
to attract foreign investment the Ravi
City spanning more than 40 000 hectares
is expected to bring in 10 billion
dollars
Ruda says the development would provide
high density purpose-built housing and
have ample green spaces
Pakistan has the highest rate of
urbanization in South Asia successive
governments have failed to provide basic
services and the population is growing
at almost two percent a year
there are no wastewater treatment plants
and almost 30 000 liters of untreated
sewage flows into the river every day
that combined with reduced water volumes
Upstream due to dams in India have made
the Ravi a sludge carrier the
Development Authority says that it wants
to treat about a thousand q6 of raw
sewage which is dumped into the river
Ravi but environmentalists are concerned
they say the harm to benefit ratio is
not balanced the state of Pakistan the
government of Punjab is not a real
estate developer they serve the people
of Pakistan what's this project going to
do that the government hasn't been able
to do in the last 75 years you can
double the population of Lahore using
higher densities and only take a couple
hundred square kilometers to do so you
can do that it just is about how you
plan the city and how you design the
city and who you're selling it to
and finding that balance between
investors looking for profit and
providing basic services and affordable
housing to a growing population will be
no easy
Tasker Lahore